trader clochard scientifique ouvrière
dans manifesto film tracts en salles fin
mai kate blanchet tu campes une douzaine
de personnages à elle seule un exercice
sur mesure pour la présidente du jury du
prochain festival de cannes qui peut à
la fois tourné avec les plus grosses
pointures d'hollywood et l'airé alain
des arts theater chef de file du
mouvement féministe et égérie pour une
grande marque de luxe
pierre michel dresse pour chicza le
portrait de cet immense actrice caméléon
à gaza et elle est la présidente du
prochain festival de cannes est bientôt
à l'affiché d'un film marty et ce fut un
gros écart de plus pour cate blanchette
et la routine pour l'australienne que
l'on surnomme le caméléon ken loach est
elle a quand même une palette de jeu qui
est totalement oui une sdf une ouvrière
spécialisée ou une instit qui cite d'une
jarre bush
manifesto de julian grosse pelle ses
treize fois kate bush est un condensé de
l'actrice tel qu'on l'a toujours vu sur
grand écran qu'on sait pas la girl next
door du tout c'est quelqu'un qui arrive
tout de suite avec une sorte de fantasme
en fait aux ménagères mais vraie
amoureuse femmes au bord de la crise de
nerfs ou tout bonnement braqueuses kate
blanchet c'est aussi une égérie de mode
bref l'amalgamme de l'autorité et du
charme
elle soutient time's up incarne une
certaine force tranquille du féminisme
mais c'est faire connaître son point de
vue c'est marrant c'est féminisme au
calme n'est pas non plus allé à paris le
festival de cannes a promis une
présidente engagé c'est fait qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont pourtant se pose qui est
qu'elle blanchette l'élégante la
classique la femme à l'air faussement
réservé où la femme un peu cru voir un
peu cache sûrement les deux n'est ce pas
cette légère bipolarité qui explique son
succès
[Musique]
[Rires]
cinquante films deux oscars bref une
carrière qui en impose mais qui connaît
vraiment kate blanchet tu puisses b elle
reste assez confidentiel même s'il a
fait des blockbusters un sac est
étonnant ça va peut-être avec son
personnage très élégant un peu effacée
elle fait partie de ces stars qui
n'existe dans l'inconscient collectif
qu'à travers les rôles qu'elle
interprète depuis les night is pourtant
kate blanchet tu sais la reine
d'hollywood win win
elle et galadriel chez peter jackson où
elle a dans thor rania rock et folk oui
mais elle est surtout cette actrice un
peu old school
un réveil vol de la blonde
hitchcockienne qui rappelle à hollywood
ce que le mot star un jour signifier
c'est la star absolue et elle a quand
même je trouve dans son attitude ou à
travers les rôles qu'elle interprète une
espèce de d'autorité naturelle
d'élégance qui peut incarner la star
hollywoodienne dans toute sa splendeur
on a presque l'impression qu'elle sort
d'un film des années 50
en fait elle est pas tellement 21ème
siècle face à la radio ce qu'ils ont
fait aussi une icône classics son
rapport à la sexualité
pas convaincu par la nudité à toutry
blanchette ne se dévoilent jamais et
tient à garder un voile entre elle et le
spectateur
cate blanchette n'est jamais sûr des
rôles sexualisé objet de désir
non non c'est très très rares elles
restent elles restent cérébrale regardez
toute sa filmographie à part peut-être
dans carole et encore la sexualité là
elle est cadenassé elle est étouffé les
retenues
[Musique]
tu
où
blanchette c'est pourtant la modernité
avec un air de ne pas y toucher qu'elle
incarne la grande bourgeoise la femme
des années 50 ou des dix comme
transgressif comme katherine hepburn
bientôt la productrice lucille ball kate
blanchet cherche à jouer les héroïnes
faussement normes et en cela elle
rappelle - grace kelly qu'une gina
rowland
[Musique]
l âge la desperate housewives par
exemple mais mes folles qui pète un
plomb
elle a joué la fin des années 50 mais
qui avait une relation homosexuelle
donc en fait c'est comme si elle nous
ramener à des images d'épinal du passé
et que elle réussissait vraiment à les
briser à chaque fois thing about this
link joe johnston turner btb sec et du
coup on est toujours cette balance la
entre le personnage très
cinématographique est quelqu'un qui
finalement il ya même un grain en fait
cardio lloris quelques hommes à bord
[Musique]
derrière la beauté ratti qu'il y a donc
une grande dame élégante mais un peu
zinzin une blonde solaire mais avec un
côté sombre en 2012 deux ans avant
claude jasmin elle l'avait révélé sur la
scène du théâtre de la ville dans
meegens paul de botho strauss c'est
extrêmement impressionnant c'est à dire
que le plateau était nu et au début du
spectacle elle était seule assise sur
une chaise et avait un espèce de silence
qui se faisait elle prenait tout son
temps et là se mettent à parler et quand
vous avez la voix de cate blanchett
cette voie un peu de cave qui est oui
qui à la fois caressante enveloppante et
en même temps il ya toujours une sorte
de petite menace
derrière elle était absolument
stupéfiante cette voie cate blanchette
celle utilisée pour se faire entendre et
là encore casser son image un pubis
[Musique]
quand elles parlent ces pourparlers
cause des femmes et ça bien avant
l'affairé weinstein
en réalité c'est peu dire que l'actrice
a le féminisme chevillée au corps
derrière cette élégance elle va pouvoir
sortir des trucs extrêmement trash et
c'est là où elle est forte parce qu'elle
le fait avec un chic et un esprit qui du
coup fait que finalement en fait qu'elle
dans chatel a dit peu de choses
son féminisme quand on regarde mais ces
choses à tout le monde s'en souvient
l'exemple en 2017 lorsqu'elle parle mode
féminine ouzzine style awards
[Musique]
lorsqu'elle reçoit son oscar pour blood
jasmin fin 2014 elle dit voilà c'est la
preuve je suis la preuve vivante qu'on
peut faire des films dont les femmes
sont les personnages principaux et
qu'ils vendent
pendant longtemps on a cru qu'un des
films qui parlent de femmes c'était des
films de femmes et el habib annoncé des
films en fait c'est des films c'est pas
des films de niche et ses films qui
rapportent le féminisme à la sauce
blanche est c'est du pragmatisme
[Musique]
pas question de se contenter de
déclarations aux côtés d'autres actrices
comme natalie portman ou reese
witherspoon elle lance time's up une
fondation destinée à venir en aide aux
victimes de harcèlement sexuel
rien de symbolique et c'est peut-être
prometteur
organe avec 14 mai inscrire vos costumes
entre les structures mais je pense que
kate blanchet sera pas une simple
caution ciel vient là c'est pour une
raison
c'était que c'est qu'à mon avis elle va
amener avec elle cette idée de time's up
et puis voilà on espère qu'il y aura un
vrai mouvement autour de ce lac sera pas
un simple discours oublier pendant le rd
remise de la palme d'or verdict le 19
mai
[Musique]